Zara Larsson, welcome!
Thank you so much!
Zara, the song we just heard, ÇLike It IsÈ,
which is a new song, a song you've done with ...
Kygo and Tyga.
Yes.
The title is ÇLike It IsÈ, and it is ...
As far as I've understood, it's about what we've spoken about earlier here,
keeping a little distance.
Yes! You could say that.
But in the way one has always wanted people to keep their distance,
when they're being intrusive.
Yes. It starts like this, Çmaybe you should leave this girl alone, but you won'tÈ.
For me, the song is about a relationship that has ended,
and that this person doesn't understand that, which I ...
I think that everyone has been in that situation, that you're either that person or
you're the one who
just wants this other person to be quiet, maybe.
Or maybe in the club when they approach you, and you're like ÇI'm not interested, and you don't notice thatÈ.
It's like ...
Well, my question is, are men worse at taking hints than women?
Maybe women have
learnt that subconsciously through the years.
And if one were to generalize, I think that
women are a little better at seeing those small hints.
When has this been tiring for you?
For example, if I don't reply to 15 text messages in a row,
I'm not gonna answer the 16th.
No. And one should get that.
One should get that! Yes.
If you're going out, and you're Zara Larsson going out ...
I'm always Zara Larsson.
Yes. Yes. And also when you go out.
And if you're doing what we're not supposed to do now, but before this, going out or things like that ...
Is it harder or easier if the whole world knows that you're single?
If I am to meet someone, it's almost like I'll date someone that I think I'll marry one day.
Even though I'm very young.
In what way?
It's like this, I don't really see the point of
seeing someone who I in the future wouldn't see myself ...
I might not marry in the future.
But like, have a future with.
To marry, have children ... Why should I date someone, even though I'm 22,
that I wouldn't want to do that with?
That's how I think.
So I'm very selective with people.
And then when I first meet someone, it goes really fast, and I fall in love.
In one second.
And then you imagine the whole future?
Yes.
No.
Or, what?
Well, I was 23 myself ...
It was like that?
Yes, yes, and I had children then.
Wow, that's young when you think about it!
I'm 23 soon.
I know that since the last time we spoke ...
I remember, it was a few years ago, you were here ...
We talked about men in groups, and it caused a lot of commotion afterwards.
Because you were quite strict with men in groups.
You generalized.
Yes, I do that.
And people didn't quite understand that you ...
But since then, you've moved.
Yes. I have.
Away from home.
You lived with your mother and father, now you've moved away from home.
Yes. Now there's only girls in my apartment.
Me and my sister.
Yes, because your family is still with you, in the form of you sister.
Yes.
Who is the boss there?
I would say that that's my sister.
I tend to call her Miss Goody Two Shoes.
She isn't very happy when I say that.
What does she call you?
Maybe a slob.
Something like that.
But she is fantastic to live with.
She cooks delicious food.
She cleans really well.
She basically does everything that's needed to keep a household going. And I have to say that
I will drop to my knees and just praise mom
and dad for doing all these household things.
Because I started to think about
how I've never in my childhood walked on our floors at home
and felt one single crumb under my foot.
It has never happened!
It is so clean in my house!
Very luxurious.
But I haven't understood, until now, how much work that requires.
Exactly!
I'm like, wait, you have to vacuum almost every day!
But there's a theory about people who can stand that it's very messy,
that they have order on the inside.
While the rest of us, who are tidy on the outside, we're more like chaos ...
Ahhhh, maybe.
I don't know if that describes me.
Test that with Miss Goody Two Shoes!
I'll do that!
Last time we spoke, you talked about that you
entrusted control of your economy,
and let's face that the economy in your world is going quite well ...
Absolutely, I'm doing well. I have no reason to worry.
I hope that!
But you mother has control of it.
Yes.
Control and control ...
Well, actually. She does have quite a lot of control.
I have a credit card.
And with that you can
pay over the internet.
And electronic invoice that I'll get on email.
And I'll say to her that ÇI've spent this muchÈ.
Or I'll tell my auditor.
ÇI have to pay this much this month.È
But mom still wants ... She'll call to get
the paperwork home.
To have a look at all expenses.
ÇWhat has she spent money on?È
She wants to see what you've spent money on?
ÇWhat have you done for this amount of money?È
And often, it's a lot of dinners.
I love treating people I know.
So you treat your friends when you go out?
Absolutely. Yes.
100 percent. It's my favorite thing to do.
But that's a very expensive life.
Yes, absolutely. But also ...
I don't know, somewhere ...
Of course, there's not a lot of people my age who have as much money as I do.
At least not my friends.
Who study or are unemployed right now or
who have some kind of job and who might not afford to go to this
new restaurant that I want to go to.
And I don't want to sit there by myself!
With a bag of cash.
Of the things you've bought, what has caused the strongest reaction from your mother?
There really isn't anything that shocks her, except the fact that I ...
She is very proud. My parents are very proud.
They would never let me pay for anything.
Even if I'm like, ÇI know that you want to go on a holiday now. Just say where you want to go, and we'll fix itÈ!
ÇNo! No! Dad and I have our own.È They're very proud.
But then, sometimes when I treat my friends, they'll be like
ÇHah! You never invite me and dad!È
ÇBut that's because you don't want that.È
But I enjoy making people happy.
But I don't think anything shocks her ...
But I actually don't do a lot of crazy things.
You look at young people who
have become successful
and have got some money in the bank
and spend them on crazy things.
I wouldn't say that I do that. I have my apartment,
I would love to buy another apartment.
In L.A.
Yes, because you've dreamt of moving to L.A.?
Exactly.
I want to go there.
It doesn't look very ..?
I know! I was going to move in 2020. I thought it would be my year.
Not so much.
Have you ever experienced being
at work, and out traveling, and just felt
ÇI have to go homeÈ? ÇI have to go home to Sweden.È
Mhm. It's happened once.
And it was terrible.
What happened then?
It tends to happen to me at the end of the year.
I tend to become sick.
Because my body is like Çit's over now, I can restÈ.
The adrenaline disappears?
Yes, a little like that.
And in that particular moment I was extremely heartbroken as well.
I had a lot of anxiety. I had slept poorly.
And i just wanted to go home to mom.
I just wanted to go home to mom.
So I did something that I had never done before, or after, actually.
I just said, and it was like a movie,
ÇYou're going to put me on the next flight to Sweden. I'm going home. Tonight.È
ÇCancel everything.È
I had a gig.
I just wanted to go home.
So you were supposed to go on stage?
Not that exact night, but the night after.
So you cancelled?
Yes.
And I'm really not the kind of person to do that.
But sometimes ...
But the homesickness took over?
Yes. And sometimes
you have to let that happen.
Better that I then cancelled one gig
and felt that that was okay.
It was actually my manager who said
ÇIf you can't do this, you're allowed to go home.È
And I've always thought of my career as life and death.
But it isn't.
It's my life, actually.
And if I'm feeling shitty in a situation,
I think that my priority should be to not feel like shit.
In those moments, pop music is just pop music?
It's like that. So then I went home to mommy.
Zara, it's wonderful to have you back.
It's good to be here!
We're having another guest on.
Bring'em in!